if you're not willing to be the worst
and to be terrible you'll never be the
best because when Mike Tyson went into a
boxing gym the first time he was
terrible and if he wasn't willing to get
beat up he couldn't have become what he
became and that goes for any fighter and
any wrestler anything you do if you're
not willing to stink initially you can't
get to the next level because if you
could show up and be awesome on day one
then what the would you want to be
the best at it for if anyone can show up
and be awesome the point of having some
something that's important to you an
accomplishment is that it took
perseverance if you can't persevere
through some discomfort you can't get to
like the promis line you can't get to
the top of the mountain unless you're
willing to persevere up the like hot
middle section where you're like
question in your like decision and I I
believe that you can practice that
ability to persevere through anything
it's like jumping in the ocean and being
like hey I got to swim to that Island
over there well the only way I'm going
to get there is if I jump in and start